and with the holidays quickly
approaching millions of people are going
to be celebrating very differently this
year because of cobit 19 but
really just how different eight news now
reporter madison kimbrough spent the day
talking to locals to hear their plans
for the holiday and she joins us now
live madison
yes hello to gather or not to gather
that is really the question here
but thanksgiving being less than two
weeks away we talked to several
los vegans who say that staying home
this year is their safest bet
i have family out of town so i'm not
going there and they're not coming here
home for the holidays has reached a
whole new meaning this year with covet
cases increasing
people are canceling big family plans
and staying home
celebrating with just their inner circle
around them i'm going to have
just my brother my sister-in-law over
for dinner
i was going to go see my fiance in
florida until the governor
came down with all the stay-at-home
things and
since the cases are going sky you know
through the roof
i'm probably just going to stay home
samantha owad plans on spending turkey
day skiing in utah but says she won't be
alone
and while staying safe is key seeing her
friends is a non-negotiable
i feel like people are going to be doing
what they want you know
and regardless like it when it comes to
family time you should take precautions
of course
the cdc recommends if you plan on having
more than four people
gather outside space out the chairs wear
masks and have one person serving food
with gloves and a face covering keep
music levels down so people don't have
to shout or speak loudly to be heard
now overall the people that we spoke to
today said that they do have family from
out of state that they normally would
travel to sea but this year
it is not an option for them reporting
live madison kimbrough 8 news 8.